welcome back to new rockstars i'm philip
molina and this is fitness origins it's
a fitness competition show inspired by
the movies at the mcu
okay guys last week i made the guys
workout
anytime anywhere apologies for leaving
in the middle of a recording
but also that's not ideal i was just
trying to prove a point so this week
i want to talk about how much more
important it is to set a firm strict
fitness routine and really try to stick
with it
that is definitely the ideal so let's
see if i can get the guys to
make some room on their schedules for
health
hey guys how's it going hi phillip
feeling fit
feeling fabulous still ready for week
three uh
and i know last week was a little bit
chaotic with having to work out at
totally random times but i do hope you
were able to see that as long as you're
flexible with what you're doing
and when you do it you can kind of get a
workout in any time
right yes yeah and you know me
flexibility is my specialty
well also though it's important that you
guys realize
that building in a routine is the true
key to fitness success
so listen up maggots you got time to
tickle your little wieners every day
then you got time to do a workout each
day so starting today
i want you all to work out at six
o'clock
every day bright and early that's
perfect i go to bed at eight
o'clock what is the sign of
you're like like was almost
characterized what that's a clown
character i'm clearly a drill sergeant
do you know how hard i've been working
on this what do you do maggots laughing
at
sorry sir sir joking around sorry
yes sir no sir sorry do you guys know
how captain america got so jacked
you think it was super soldier serum it
was military discipline
and a strict steroid routine as well yes
okay but he had to get those shots at
regular intervals
and that's also a routine and i want you
guys again confirm
six o'clock workouts every day uh
i think i can commit to six o'clock yeah
i'll be there
what do you mean you think all right i
will i will i will god she just took a
turn
uh week three day one i feel more
confident doing all those exercises i
feel like
i've come a long way things are starting
to get a little bit easier
definitely waking up with more energy
you know it's the usual battle i'm still
working on
trying to get this routine down don't
want to work out
work out feel amazing the human brain is
a fascinating thing
i almost didn't make it to uh to even
get started today
part of the discipline is i think tuning
out distractions this is really hard
it's really daunting this one
for instance that workout i just had but
i had two phone calls
and an email come in that distracted me
what should have been a
12-15 minute workout took me almost half
an hour to finish you know even with one
minute rests in between
it's really hard discipline's gonna be
tough for me motivation's gonna be tough
for me but
i feel better i feel motivated i'm glad
i did it
my brother is an active duty navy my dad
was an evil officer for 30 years and i
always knew them
to be very fit so that's what i'm trying
to do now
after a workout i was just i did one of
these
wow there is some mass there that wasn't
there before
eric has been pretty competitive in
making some really big strides in his
fitness and this is captain america week
and we all know cap
was only able to become an avenger once
he froze himself in ice
so desperate times call for desperate
measures
okay all right that was pretty bad
[Music]
oh okay i can feel myself getting
stronger
all right guys good morning day five
how's it feeling good morning
phillip yeah all right tommy's gotten on
board
why are we doing this why are we doing
this it's day five of your of your six
a.m workouts come on eric you're always
a morning person if you never go to bed
i have to say you never said six am you
just said bright and early at six and
i'm like with daylight savings it's
pretty
bright and early i'm a night owl well
wait roll the tape john
i want you all to work out at six
o'clock
every day bright and early
i guess if you've been working out at 6
pm consistently that still proves a
point that it's easier
to make time for something if you just
build it into your day
tell me how many workouts did you get
let's say i did less than five
more than one and split it right down
the middle with the three that i did
that's still pretty good actually
honestly like from where you were
to being able to hit three workouts a
week
consistently there's plenty of people
have completely changed their lives on
three workout days a week so i don't
want you to think that that's
you know nothing my greatest enemy it
has been
time
i did not do this at a at 6 a.m as i was
supposed to
but just hitting that routine and that
schedule was was so
difficult and you just in a way it's
even more difficult i kind of wish i had
started at 6 a.m just to get it out of
the way but now when you
you're looking at the clock all day and
you're like i have this many things that
i have to finish right now
i i'm still like self-conscious about
looking stupid working out so when my
roommates are around i don't want to
inconvenience them and ask them to leave
so i can go work out so that's my
biggest struggle i have the time i'm not
as busy as eric
but i have uh a lot more of the like
insecurity i guess
well and now you guys kind of understand
why the goal was to have you work out at
6am because eric's totally right
get it out of the way just start start
the day with it honestly you have a much
better
day so you feel better and you don't
have to worry about it you don't
associate it with stress it's a great
way to wake up
uh i've got i've got something special
planned for you guys i think it might
lift your spirits
because of that i'm actually not gonna
ask you guys for your cheat meal orders
this week
but don't worry i have something special
in mind cookie decorating
and guys just this is to everybody uh
watching just a new fitness journey is
not easy and especially trying to make
time like eric's having issues
to especially to find healthy food or
get more rest or anything
luckily of course doordash is here to
help for me legitimately it frees up so
much time
to take care of my meals and my
groceries which you can get delivered
through doordash they just drop them off
right at your door and for a limited
time
of course our listeners are getting 25
often zero delivery fees off their first
order of 15
or more when you download the doordash
app and enter that code
nerd fitness whoa whoa 25 oh
but it is a 25 off up to a 10 value
uh zero delivery piece on your first
order when you download the doordash app
in the app store under code nerdfitness
don't forget that code nerdfitness 25
off somebody teach tommy that man
25 off uh and you guys still have a
6 a.m workout to do
a little rain nice dripping eric well
well well
look who it is oh phillip why did you
invite us to this haunted warehouse
good question it's time for another
challenge okay
i figured that was important guys in mcu
release order this is a big one
you know what's next the avenger
and this movie's the long way to team up
of captain america iron man thor
hawkeye black widow and of course the
incredible hulk yes
okay in this movie they'll have to work
together to fight off loki and the
chitari so that means that in this
challenge you're actually not going to
be competing against each other this
time
you're working together and if you both
win
you get some delicious shawarma brought
to you by doordash if you lose everyone
dies
and it's not the avengers it's not a
team right so welcome your teammates off
screen
zack and marina mastros
[Applause]
friends friends friends friends friends
friends friends
friends see the point of this challenge
is all about
finding a support team and so hey now
you got people to support you on your
fitness endeavor
but also this challenge is gonna test a
lot of the skills that hopefully you've
been picking up along the way
like coordination and your flexibility
so in this challenge
you're gonna work together with your
friends in a space i set up to complete
an objective okay so a room we have to
escape it is not an escape room
you will find clues inside of the space
in an escape room
hate escape rooms but fine it's a marvel
themed
fitness challenge escape room brought to
you by jordan yay
let's get started
hold up this is an escape room
right right greetings i am phillip
fabricated intelligence and logistical
ultimatum presenter
so just fill up all right everyone the
portal has been opened above new york
city and the chitauri forces are pouring
through
to initiate the invasion in order to
stop them and complete this challenge
you're gonna have to assemble all of
your individual fitness skills
to close the portal and save the city i
have used my superior intellect
to devise a series of tasks that will
ensure the safety of the world
you okay eric i'm fine i'm getting
through this
you got notes i think later we were
bumped by superior intellect i think is
what stopped us
how is my intellect not superior it's
just we assume you wrote this
all right work fast and get that portal
closed so you can all enjoy
some delicious shawarma okay i mean now
it's escape room so we're looking for
clues
oh wait no here's one here's one found a
clue all right
uh this reads before the battle can
truly start
we have to rev up your human heart
oh yeah get your heart rate up since my
reskin heart rate's at
62 so i guess i'll just jump
hug heart rate measure initiated
goal of 150 beats per minute
extended periods i found something oh
another clue
no matter how the battle goes the hulk
always loses his clothes hey
[Applause]
there was more stuff near the envelope
oh
for the lava
some jazzy threads see some purple pants
purple pants with a hulk
throw them on bud
so oh so you have to tear that off we
need you to get angry big man let me
tell you something brother
my secret is i'm always hungry angry
i can hear it
right along the seam lines where it's
most difficult to rip
i feel like this is just punishment for
you saving the world can be fun
but it takes leader to get it done
gather together all your grunts and make
them do
50 push-ups
[Music]
i love push-ups so this this plays
i also love push-ups so let's get to it
huh
this is a slick rug one two well
who are you counting zack zuck's going
the fastest
and uh let's just say i think you guys
are done you've done five i did seven
i just done five and uh
now this is honestly a lot i'm gonna say
he's uh
do i look like captain america now yeah
yeah oh yeah guys
we're on a timer oh okay yeah more clues
more clues right
oh hey dude i've got one over here clue
alert
it takes a god to help these days so
lift mjolnir
high and say the phrase oh like they're
incantations
okay let's say it all together guys okay
if you be worried he shall possess the
powers of thor how am i the only one who
knows
whatever the chittari are
i maybe shouldn't have gone all out on
those push-ups your arms are activated
my friend
let's go whosoever wields this hammer
if he'd be worthy so we'll devour
i just tear some more clothes off what
do you think
eric heart rate update 50
150. all right so black widow spy skills
can do the trick but sometimes it takes
a mighty kick line your team members up
right
and kick as high as the shortest height
you're probably the shortest right no
you're still pretty tall marina
that's a pretty good height to kick over
all right give it your best
shot
spirit squad be with me
[Music]
unfortunately you're 30 seconds from the
atari taking over
oh here's here's one just like hawkeye
the best avenger uh we all are mortal
but if we hit the bullseye we'll close
the portal
that's the bullseye oh there's some uh
darts here
not darts just little nukes with pointy
tips
[Music]
come on come on eight
seven six
five
[Music]
hold four hold on oh god
it's a hit
thousands of satori are dead
[Music]
you did it you assembled your avengers
and closed the portal
captured loki and put an end to phase
one
you're all winners this week and that
means you all get to dig
into some delicious shawarma oh yes
so it looks like this week everybody
wins you included
guys i really am so proud of my buddies
here
also thanks so much to you guys for your
comments on challenge ideas keep them
coming they're really useful
oh also for those of you that have been
asking right around now ish
the workouts that eric and tommy have
been doing are now available for you
to do along with them all you gotta do
is head on over to the epic hero fitness
youtube channel to start working out
with the exact same routines
remember this could be your origin story
too
all right please make sure to share this
video it helps so much
i've been philip molina and i'll see you
next time on fitness origins
too bad marina died
[Music]
you